It's time for battle of the bites ice cream.
We're lucky enough to do it with Jesse and Julie and me.
And of course, Rossi Ross Mathews.
Hi guys, hi!
We're so excited to do this with you guys.
Look at what a motley crew I'm so excited.
(laughter)
Okay. Well the winning ice cream shop gets the cherry on top
and the claims of the majestic battle of the bites trophy.
It's rocking the ice cream today.
Wow.
Ding. Let's get into it.
First step is sugary Hill Creamery from Harlem New York.
Take a look.
I'm Patricia Bazan Larson.
This is Nick Larson.
We're the co-founders and co-owners of sugar Hill Creamery.
Sugar Hill Creamery is a family owned ice cream shop
that serves small batch ice cream made
by our resident ice cream maker.
We strongly believe in using raw ingredients
and using good ingredients to create our ice creams.
The flavors are informed
by our Caribbean and Midwestern cultures.
We are inspired by our family heritage.
As we create flavors that we share
with other families and Harlem restaurants.
I love it.
Jesse and Julie, a man and a woman teaming
up to make fantastic food and ingredients.
All right, here we go.
Look at me.
You go, I'm ready.
This first one has Butterscotch in it.
Yeah, and like a little he's bar kind of
tastes too like the inside of a Heath bar.
Mm that's delicious.
Mm hmm. That's good.
Mm hmm
Mm. Definitely
Really good.
It's like if you put a dark chocolate bar in the freezer
The vanilla was quite interesting, Jessie
The vanilla is definitely my favorite of this batch here.
Wow. That was delicious.
Holy cow.
Drew that was utterly hilarious.
(laughter)
All right, let's go
to our next dreamy business up next with ice cream.
Do you believe from Washington DC?
Let's take a look.
I'm Victoria Lai.
I'm the founder and chief ice cream-preneur
of ice cream jubilee.
Here in our nation's capital, Washington, DC.
I became a government lawyer here in DC, but soon
after I realized that I was missing the colors
and the flavors and the excitement
and the joy that comes with sharing ice cream.
So in my own apartment, I started mixing in flavors
and taking inspiration for anywhere,
I could find it.
I was living a life full of colors and flavors
and it was my dream.
I hope you enjoy our ice cream
and try more flavors at icecreamjubilee.com.
(applause)
I love her story.
She was like a Washington DC lawyer
and was like, I'm not happy.
I want to go make ice cream.
That's the definition of a pivot.
Absolutely, and yet it's such a good example
to us all to find our dream
in this sort of life is short, but beautiful scenario.
Okay, here we go.
Ice cream Jubilee.
I'm starting with the cherries Jubilee
because you know,
Oh my God.
Hmm.
Okay
Okay. That's so good.
I'm not getting
Sorry
not the cherries as much as yes.
I taste more bananas, but it's beautiful.
Drew, could you take a trip to that Top scoop?
It's the banana, bourbon one.
Wait, maybe I am eating the banana Bourbon one.
(laughter)
that might explain a few things.
I'm like, I'm not really getting cherry.
(laughter)
Jessie,
Julie, which one are you guys eating and liking?
I'm going to say
I love any cherry dessert, this cherry ice cream.
I like that the cherry's subtle
It's almost like a mint chip.
Like the flex of a chocolate in there.
This is slamming.
Well, what's crazy about what she's done is
in the cookies and cream, the cookie is fluffy.
How did it not get like dense, wet and like smushed?
It's like it's fluffy.
Mm Hmm.
I don't really get it.
It's confusing and amazing.
I've never heard a cookie described as fluffy, I love it.
Don't sleep on that banana though.
I can't stop digging in on that.
It's I really I'm with Julie.
I really loved the cherry as well.
Okay. Finally, we have made our way South
with lick honest ice screams from Austin, Texas
take a lick and I mean, take a look.
Hey, drew and friends, I'm Chad
and I'm Anthony.
And we're the co-founders of
like honest ice creams in Austin, Texas.
We make what we call honest ice creams.
And for us, that means knowing where every ingredient
comes from and using super clean ingredients.
And that starts with our milk and cream
which come from a local family owned dairy
about an hour and a half from our production kitchen.
We have scoop shops and Austin and San Antonio.
If you can't make it here, get on gold Valley.
We ship across the country.
Thanks for having us.
Enjoy it.
Thank you.
Alright guys.
They couldn't be cuter those two.
I was thinking the same thing.
All righty, then coffee with cream.
It's backwards.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum
Oh, Jesse.
There's a Hill country, honey and vanilla bean just for you.
I'm obsessed with all these vanilla flavors,
and they're all so different.
It's crazy that there is a difference
between the sugar Hill one and the lick one.
Right?
And then the last is Texas sheet cake.
Sheet cake is one of the first desserts I ever made.
I love, love, love Texas sheet cake.
So I'm a fan of this ice cream too.
My favorite
from the lick honest ice creams is the coffee
The coffee! I was just going to say the coffee.
Are you guys ready?
The moment has come.
Are we ready to vote?
Yes.
This is hard.
I know it is hard. Alright.
That said the time has come one at a time.
We're going to reveal our favorites.
All right.
I'll jump in and get, just do it.
I'm going to go Sugar Hill Creamery.
Okay.
Ross?
All right. I'm voting with you, Sugar Hill Creamery.
Julie, it's your turn.
You know, I gotta go with Jubilee
It was really, really good.
Okay. Jesse, what have you got?
Someone's going to have to make an extra trophy,
because it's a tie.
(cheering)
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so guess what? We get a two for both ice cream shops
they're each getting a trophy and a battle of the bite win!
I love this. That is fantastic.
That makes me so happy. And to get the scoop
on some of our favorite ice cream shops around the country.
Excuse me.
(laughter)
I think I just became lactose intolerant. This second.
Get the scoop on some
of our favorite ice cream shops from around the country.
Visit our website TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
And this is the cookbook you cannot live without
Jesse Tyler Ferguson and Julie Tannis,
Food Between Friends is available now.
Wherever books are sold, get it while it's hot.